diese shell inselparadies im indischen
ozean palmen weiße sandstrände türkises
wasser ewiger sommer gerade jetzt in
corona zeiten ein sehnsuchtsort aber
nicht für alle
die seychellen haben ein massives
drogenproblem
wir sind unterwegs in den ghettos der
hauptstadt victoria mit den beamten der
zuständigen sondereinheit der polizei
die nicht gezeigt werden dürfen
fast jeden tag machen sie solche razzien
immer zu anderen tageszeiten sagt uns
gem
der chef des teams wir müssen den
drogenverkauf einfach stören
wir müssen das tun das bringt unser land
um
es ist ein täglicher kampf für uns und
oft ein frustrierender denn wenn die
beamten auftauchen sind viele dieser
meist schon über alle berge oder haben
den stoff einfach weggeworfen wenn dann
könnten sie nur kleine mengen es macht
schnell die runde wenn die sondereinheit
unterwegs ist es hat vor einer ganzen
weile begonnen
es ist vielleicht zu acht neun jahre her
dass wir ernste probleme mit heroin
bekamen die leute waren ihr morgens auf
und sagen ich brauche geld in der tasche
aber dafür müssen sie arbeiten
sie denken es ist ein lifestyle drogen
zu verkaufen
mai zu werden und party zu machen aber
das ist kein lifestyle die seychellen
haben die höchste rate an
heroinabhängigen weltweit zehn prozent
der arbeitsfähigen bevölkerung so der
jüngste kriminalitäts berichten vor
einigen jahren änderte die regierung
ihrer anti drogen strategie fast jeden
tag sind nun methadon busse unterwegs
allein während der korona pandemie ist
die zahl der teilnehmer am
methadonprogramm von 1500 auf 3500
gestiegen
womöglich weil viele süchtige kein geld
mehr für drogen haben die wirtschaft der
inseln leidet etwa am massiven rückgang
an touristen rhein ist einer der
süchtigen er ist erst 24 und bereits
täglich auf die kostenlose ersatz
substanz angewiesen sie unterdrückt
entzugserscheinungen
und hilft ihm seinen alltag zu
bewältigen ich habe vor zwei jahren
damit angefangen und ich sehe dass mir
das methadon hilft ich habe es gerade
eben genommen
damit kann ich lange arbeiten ich fühle
mich nicht krank ich kann nachts
schlafen reihen stammt aus einfachen
verhältnissen seien corsa hat ihn zum
heroin gebracht damit begann der übliche
drogen teufelskreis heute verkauft der
früchte zieht morgens los klettert auf
bäume und mangos avocados und andere
tropische früchte zu ernten die er am
strand verkauft eine jak frucht haben
wir schon wir warten ein zwei tage dann
halbieren wir sie und schneiden sie in
vier stücke jedes kostet 50 rupien
umgerechnet sind das etwa zwei euro 40
mit seinem kleinen stand am meer kann
sich rein ganz gut über wasser halten
seine kunden sind touristen jetzt in
combat zeiten kommen nur wenige aber
dennoch muss rein nicht stehlen wie
früher als junkie zwei jahre saß er
deswegen im gefängnis begann danach mit
dem methadon warum er überhaupt
angefangen hat weiß rein nicht genau und
es fällt ihm schwer zu erklären warum
ausgerechnet hier im paradies so viele
süchtig werden
keine ahnung was das problem ist
vielleicht weil es keine jobs gibt also
verfallen die kids den drogen
sie gehen los suchen arbeiter befinden
keine deshalb gehen sie ins ghetto genau
dort zeigt sich das ganze ausmaß in
diesen vierteln wird offen mit drogen
gedealt und konsumiert nur einer lässt
sich dabei sind mittlerweile gibt es
weniger heroinabhängiger als noch vor
ein paar jahren dafür sind kokain und
crack auf dem vormarsch hören wir rund
zwölf prozent beträgt die
jugendarbeitslosigkeit auf den
seychellen derzeit das ist deutlich
höher als vor corona aber längst nicht
alle süchtigen sind arbeits oder
perspektivlos die sucht ziehe sich durch
alle schichten und altersgruppen sagt
giralda die super die chefin des
programms wir fragen unsere klienten
immer was hat dich zu den drogen
gebracht und es gibt verschiedene gründe
bei einigen sind es die sozialen
umstände die probleme zu hause dann
gruppendruck oder die verfügbarkeit der
drogen auf dem markt der grund dafür
könnte sein dass die seychellen an der
so genannten stadt anliegen der
südlichen route das heroin findet seinen
weg von afghanistan über iran und
pakistan nach ostafrika
die sicherheitsbehörden der sich allen
versuchen den schmuggel zu unterbinden
fahren regelmäßig auf patrouille und
durchsuchen schiffe
nur selten aber gelingt ihnen dabei ein
pfund wie in diesem fall ein iranischer
fischkutter wird aufgebracht und ein
paket drogen sichergestellt
die küstenlinie der 115 inseln sei
einfach zu lang sagt romanus encore vom
anti drogen büro ist unsere seegebiete
sind wirklich massiv sehr groß und es
gibt einfach viele aktivitäten die in
diesem gebiet passieren und mit unseren
limitierten ressourcen ist es unmöglich
gegen die drogen zu kämpfen
deswegen versuchen wir proaktiv zu
handeln indem wir die hilfe unserer
internationalen partner suchen
es ist ein schwieriger kampf gegen die
drogen im paradies am strand nach dreien
feierabend für diesen tag er will es
schaffen auch das methadon hinter sich
zu lassen
er träumt von einer familie und einem
normalen leben
[Musik]